[Music]
the problem is not Trump Trump is a
symptom if the problem with Trump it
wouldn't be happening on the places
around the world we actually see all
sorts of countries advanced industrial
democracies where people are getting
angrier and they're voting more and more
against the establishment we saw that
with the brexit referendum which was
before the u.s. presidential election we
saw in Germany with the rise of the
alternatives for Deutschland a actively
Euroskeptic party for the first time
since World War two
we have nationalists in the German
parliament we sought with recent Italian
elections where they threw out all of
the establishment parties and instead
it's the five star movement and the
League again Euroskeptic
anti-immigration populist political
forces this is very unusual and it's not
coincidence so why is it happening one
reason is because you have lots of
members of working and middle classes
that feel like they are not doing well
economically and no one in the
establishment is gonna help them
so let's vote for some change let's vote
against free trade let's vote against
the support of the establishment let's
bring in something new a second point a
lot of this is anti-immigration
demographics have changed an awful lot
in the United States in Canada and in
Europe over the past decades and a lot
of people feel people that have come
before say wait a second you're not
taking care of me but you're gonna bring
in these new people and these new people
who I don't necessarily like or
understand or trust these new people who
are getting benefits but what about my
benefits it's gonna cost a lot of money
to bring them in are they gonna steal my
jobs are they gonna cause crime even
though the United States we know that
first generation immigrants don't
actually cause more crime than those
that live have lived here nonetheless
the willingness to believe that those
other people are bad and a problem goes
up a lot when you feel like your
governments not taking care of you so
that's been a big piece of it a third
piece has been the military you know the
foreign policy establishment in the
United States has been very willing to
support the u.s. getting into wars
around the world but most of the sons
and daughters of the foreign policy
establishment don't actually fight in
those Wars themselves that's also true
of the political leaders that are
responsible as we know you know it's the
poor people it's the enlisted men and
women they get sent off their families
are left broken their communities are
hindered they come back Iraq Afghanistan
billions upon billions of dollars wasted
on these wars enormous numbers of people
that are killed or wounded or have
post-traumatic stress disorder they come
back they're not seen as heroes the
Americans and the Allies didn't win
these wars the Veterans Administration
doesn't take care of them so as a
consequence you see those people getting
really angry and not voting for Hillary
or Jeb they're voting for Bernie Sanders
or for Donald Trump and then you have
technology which is that technology
today is increasingly driving people
apart we get most of our information in
the United States from advertising
companies that view us as commodities
products they want they sell our
eyeballs and our time on their sites to
companies that pay money to ensure that
we spend as much time as possible on
Facebook and on Twitter and the rest
that's how we get our information we'll
spend more time on their sites if we are
divided and we are narrower and only
follow the things we like which means
Democrats are watching Pro Democrat
sites and conservatives and Republicans
are watching Pro Republican sites and
there's virtually no overlap and so it's
fake news for everybody it's us versus
them that's happening across Europe it's
happening in Canada those four factors
are driving us apart they're ripping at
the fabric of civic nationalism across
all of the advanced industrial economies
and by the way it's happening when the
economy is doing really well the United
States today and the UK and Canada and
Germany feel more divided than
any time in my lifetime and yet that's
when we can spend a lot of money so if
that's true what do you think it's gonna
feel like when interest rates go up and
growth goes down and we start laying
people off and we don't have the
budgetary space to give everybody a tax
break it's gonna get worse
so it's very clear that this is a
structural condition that we have been
living with and ignoring for decades and
it's getting worse one interesting point
there's one country among the advanced
industrial democracies that's not
experiencing this problem at all
and that's Japan if you go to Japan
you'll actually find that the people are
pretty much just as happy and trusting
of their political institutions their
leaders their media as they were 30 40
years ago now let's look at all of the
factors that I just described that are
causing problems in our country's
economic erosion of the working class in
Japan the population is shrinking fast
from now to 2050 it's gonna shrink by
another 15% which means that even though
the Japanese economy is not growing per
capita they're doing a lot better so
they don't feel so bad
immigration Japanese actually let in
almost nobody so as a consequence
there's no one that they really have a
backlash against it's all Japanese right
number three the military united states
fights and lots of wars suit our allies
Japan does not their military is
constitutionally forbidden from going
abroad and fighting in wars when they
did support us in Iraq they sent a few
hundred Japanese they kept them far away
from any fighting every soldier had like
a million dollars of insurance they made
sure that they were calling their
families every week they really didn't
have backlash against the military and
finally social media technology where
the Japanese as a government has worked
hard to keep social media out of the
political space and the average Japanese
adult isn't on social media only about
thirty nine percent of them are compared
to well over majority in the West so the
one country in the world among the
wealthy democracies that isn't
experiencing a crisis of democracy is
the one that kind of rejected globalism
and its precepts over the last 40 years
[Music]